irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
mais amiens nous quittions coup secours
et nous abordons aujourd'hui le mur de
sa ska ouamane un vaste empire qui
témoigne encore d extraordinaire
connaissance et de l'intelligence de
cette trace
les fouilles entreprises depuis de
nombreuses années ont permis en plus des
objets rituels de découvrir des tombeaux
dans un état de parfaite conservation
la paille tressée cette paille tressée
forme le linceul d'une momie
n'ayez pas peur elles sont passées dans
la légende blotti dans leur sommeil
vieille de nombreux siècles
contrairement aux égyptiens qui
embaumait les corps dans la position
allongée la coutume un cas était de les
piller genoux sous le menton pour que
ceux ci retrouvent dans la mort la
position natale avant d'être enveloppé
et cousu dans de multiples toile de
différentes couleurs
l'une d'entre elles connu peut être le
secret du trésor des incas
connaissance de l'embaumement
connaissance de la chirurgie les
nombreux crâne découvert prouve que la
trépanation était une opération courante
voyez vous ce petit trou un chirurgien
contemporain tenta dernièrement la même
expérience avec les instruments
retrouver les procédés un cas
l'opération réussit
non ce n'est pas un rayon de soleil et
ce n'est pas non plus le soleil des
incas que vous voyez en ce moment mais
c'est un ensemble de cordelettes appelé
weepu et qui servait de livres de
comptabilité aux halles cat de chaque
village la couleur indiqué la nature de
la matière les ne leur nombre moyen
simple et logique de faire le
recensement d'un pays et d'en connaître
toute sa productivité
c'est au machu picchu que fut en son
temps la forteresse clés du royaume en
même temps qu'une retraite religieux que
se célébrait les rites à la gloire du
soleil dont voici le trône
voilà ce pas m
oh
comment à 3300 m d'altitude sur un pic
escarpé pouvait-on érigé de telles
masses
il est troublant de penser qu'à des
époques et sur des points différents de
notre globe change aucune communication
possibles entre eux semble-t-il des
peuples les crétois et les incas avant à
peu près les mêmes objets de parure ou
journalier les mêmes formes de céramique
et les mêmes formes de construction
ces deux civilisations sur le cam
également descendant du soleil leurs
costumes ne sont ils pas d'ailleurs
rouge et flamboyant
voici l'alcan et son fils pilote
la ferveur et le mysticisme naturel de
ce peuple allié au catholicisme espagnol
fond de l'accomplissement des rites une
fresque vivante et colorée
ils sortent touche de la messe
cette procession qui va nous conduire
vers un train
pour un autre départ ou plutôt mois la
poursuite de ce voyage
un train pourquoi mais parce que si la
vie ont raccourci la terre on s'en
détache avec l'avion tandis qu'avec un
train il semble que l'on fasse partie de
la nature
et il y a longtemps que routes sentiers
maison village on pourra me ce chemin de
fer
et dans ce train tout le marché laissé à
cusco se retrouvent il est devenu
ambulant
en
sur les quais on échange culture
bibelots fourrure et mille trésors puis
l'indigène tel un escargot grimpent le
long du wagon on s'entasse et l'on
repart
le train est généralement une trêve dans
les habitudes de chacun mais ici non la
vie continue
ban
montagnes vallées rivière défilent
ouais
et finalement on arrive à 4314 m la raya
il y fait froid on veut courir pour se
réchauffer mais bien vite le coeur vous
rappelle à l'ordre il bat il va fort
c'est un des très rares trains du monde
qui montrent aussi où
on les sent et on se rue au buffet
il est en plein air et le traditionnel
sandwich est remplacé par un agneau qui
grille sous vos yeux
déchiquette
et qu'il est rapidement du reste dévorer
il fait très fins 4314 m
certains même emporté leur parent
ou un petit peu plus que leur part
est de nouveau le voyage
il est courageuse petit train même à
cette altitude lui ne s'essouffle pas
puno
3822 m c est une des extrémités du lac
titicaca
peut-être pour combattre la protée du
pays les habitants se parent de couleurs
vives
les costumes sont très gai très
chatoyant
c'est ici que les femmes portent le
melon
et si elle ne le portaient pas un serait
tout à fait déconsidérer une femme en
cheveux est très mal venue
on est là sur des toits du monde et il
semble difficile d'être plus près du
ciel sauf peut-être à jérusalem
et la semaine prochaine nous
poursuivrons notre voyage mais en
bolivie
yam tcha lieu vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de solange péters
montage pierre michel rey sont à nick v
discrit nathalie de muret illustration
sonore denise glaser